welcome back to the iced coffee hour our
name is ketchup please so far an iced
coffee hour has made 193
000
it's probably made about 1.99 yeah it
has 7.99 that's a great guess
what a beautiful introduction thank you
guys so much for making it out here
thank you where did you travel from i
traveled from uh university of miami but
uh we're both from wisconsin great state
of wisconsin wow wow alex is this why
you uh you picked him pick in favor you
know we got to have uh you know
wisconsin representing out here
so hey go box this is entirely different
from anything else that we have done um
i've always been a fan of shark tank and
recently we partnered with carrot uh who
does a credit card to do this like
creator sort of event where we get
pitched ideas and i thought it was so
fun that i wanted to try one on this
channel here and so we have you guys who
flew all the way here we've never met
before and you're gonna pitch me your
product um
just take it away and all this is real
by the way so if it's good i'll actually
invest my own money and we'll we'll
figure out the details afterwards
all right let's let's hear it my name is
evan labsa my name is reid kastner lang
and we are the co-founders of ketchup
please llc all right so we want to start
with the most common question we get
which is why ketchup and the answer is
pretty simple in 2015 i had open heart
surgery to fix a congenital heart defect
and no that alone didn't make me think
oh i should create ketchup but
fast forward three years i was sitting
across the table just like this for my
father and he's like hey could you pass
the ketchup please and we thought well
it'd be pretty funny if you need to
catch a break ketchup please because
everybody would say ketchup please
please every time they asked for it so i
had the idea to create healthier foods
for heart patients and then
eventually had the name of ketchup
please and fast forward a year from
there i had started assembling uh kind
of the things to do it so i started a
business uh you know started making some
recipes and i got a call from reid one
day august of 2018 and he's like hey i
hear you think of starting a ketchup
business and i'm like well kind of and
he's like well i want in so uh as they
say the rest is history and we'll get
into kind of how it developed from there
so now you may be wondering what even is
the problem with ketchup or the ketchup
industry in the first place and i'm
gonna show you i'm guessing it's gotta
be health reasons right because that's
what he just so yes sodium right
so this is this is heinz right here
america yep heinz is made up of about 20
added sugar alone
heinz as you know is the number one
ketchup in america it takes up about 80
percent of the market
and ketchup please has no added sugar
along with that ketchup please is 80
less carbs 37 less sodium only 5
calories
and it's usda organic all without
compromise on flavor
this is the amount of sugar that's in a
ketchup bottle yeah and it's actually
high fructose corn syrup that's just to
illustrate but wow
yeah all right so we just want to
briefly discuss the value proposition
that ketchup police has ketchup please
is the furthest left over there
and as you can see we're not the
cheapest but compared to our competitors
we're actually right in line that's
primal kitchen g-hughes and true made
now the most important thing though is
not only are we the only organic no
sugar added in sweetened ketchup in the
world uh we actually again as we alluded
to we don't compromise on taste which
again at the end of this presentation
you'll be able to try our product and
see it for yourselves but uh you know a
lot of brands can have things that are
really healthy and cool but if it
doesn't taste good nobody's gonna buy it
so now let's get into kind of who our
team is and who we are so technically
evan and i are the only members
currently of the business but we have
some high school friends and students
like isaac and ariana pictured there who
help us at some fairs and festivals and
farmers markets and sampling in stores
but honestly like from the beginning
this has been a team effort from you
know graphic designers we have a great
graphic designer we have
all of our retailers really kind of
supported us along this this whole way
and so it's it's really a full-on team
effort so i want to briefly discuss
traction we're in almost 80 retailers
now now at the beginning of 2021 we're
only in 15 retailers so we've had very
large growth in 2021 2020 is pretty
brutal as it was for a lot of people
but up here we have some logos of just
some of the retailers we're in and the
wisconsin state fair we are where we are
proud member of the wisconsin products
pavilion so now we'll get into some of
the opportunities that we're looking to
pursue so we've actually explored a lot
of these opportunities but we haven't
been able to fully pursue them due to
inventory constraints so as you can see
on the left those are some of our
e-commerce strategies that we want to go
into shopify amazon and thrive
whole foods and arowana are two grocery
store chains that reached out to us but
we didn't really pursue due to inventory
constraints and pricing so and then on
the right we have unfi who is a natural
foods distributor to
grocery stores throughout the country us
foods which services restaurants
throughout the country in surtco which
is a smaller food distributor servicing
about 300 stores throughout wisconsin in
the midwest so product development this
is where it gets fun so we have our
original flavor which is organic and no
sugar added we have our smooth heat
version which is coming out in the next
two to three months we have that
formulation pretty much all set ready to
go and then we actually have a doge
sauce which is a ketchup and mustard
combination that i think is really going
to take ketchup please to the moon
so let's get to the bottom line here now
keep in mind these are just graphics of
our financials we we have a more
in-depth analysis as well however if you
look on the left there you can see our
total revenue type and type versus year
so the majority of our income
especially in 2021 came from events in
retail as we expanded again from 15 to
78 retailers but as we expand into 2023
2024 and 2025 hopefully with an
investment we'll be able to captivate on
scaling
channels such as retail food service and
e-commerce as you can see over time
events become less and less a portion of
our revenue just because it's extremely
difficult to scale those and it's a lot
easier to scale retail e-commerce and
food service so continuing the
financials um
this is just projected revenue versus
net profit every year now for 2019 2020
and 2021 we maintain a 30 profit margin
net profit last year we did 60 000 in
revenue and 20 000 in profit and we
expect to continue that over time as we
have economies of scale so even if our
price decreases we'll be able to
maintain that margin and by 2025 with an
investment we expect to do 260 thousand
dollars in net profit so based on all of
that in order to get our costs down and
expand into some of these new
opportunities we are asking for a
hundred thousand dollars in exchange for
twenty percent
in ketchup please
so we just wanted to briefly discuss two
where those funds will go fifty percent
of that will be going into inventory and
again the economies of scale that come
with more inventory there's a lot of
opportunities out there that we actually
haven't been able to capture mainly
because we don't have the inventory to
do it uh ten percent of that's going to
go into product development so your
smooth heat flavor doge sauce
developing those that's ten percent of
the funds twenty percent of it's going
to go into marketing that's
predominantly on e-commerce maybe a
little bit of retail and then 20 percent
of that's going to be expansion
what expansion covers is as we expand
into new retailers new markets there's
costs and things that come up that we
simply can't account for so that will
help basically give us uh
an edge uh to make sure that we can
expand uh efficiently into new retailers
and markets
and with that what do you think
try some ketchup please all right try it
let's try all right i used to love
ketchup as a kid i would put ketchup on
everything really so you'll be a good
critic yeah i would put it on broccoli
i'd put it on eggs put it on broccoli
yeah i put on it i put on it puts it on
broccoli
i liked it
ketchup and broccoli especially
so not only do we have kp here we're
putting it to the test that's a nice
sound we're playing the test with normal
hinds here we got no sugar added heinz
and we got one of our biggest
competitors down there as well it looks
like the heinz uses like a like a really
red food coloring in there yeah it looks
pretty unnatural actually i think they
do there might be food dye um oh you
brought chicken wow no
potato wedges oh my gosh yes you just
won over graham's or jack's i was going
to have a joke said if you guys had any
fries
walmart trudeau's very well today wow
alex you got to try some of this too
yeah oh actually they sent me some yeah
he's tried it already oh really
don't tell them don't tell them what you
do yeah i wanted to vet them you know
gotta had to put it to the test
graham what are you doing on your phone
dude okay so we had guys we had a
converse jack and i had a conversation
about we had a series right before this
and we agreed that anytime we do a
podcast we're confiscating your phone
gram it needs to be confiscated yeah
yeah yeah yeah
it gets cut out of every episode every
time you go on your phone it gets cut
all right so normal ketchup please is
the biggest
grouping there okay and then the rest of
it is our competitors all right so i'm
going to try well i don't want to try
that one for i know and you might want
to in between it you should probably
drink some water cleanse your palate
like sometimes it's all right let me try
i'm going to try yours first i know what
ketchup tastes like
oh no ketchup please stay like though
the moment of truth
wow i mean heinz is going
i like irons
okay try ketchup please
yep
all right so you 100 taste better than
your competitor
that's the main health conscious
competitor it's not it's not as tasty
100 so that that's easy for me we took
we took 88 batches so our junior year of
high school we were developing and we'd
bring these little two ounce cups to
school and have like a little survey
you know like all the kids and teachers
try it till we got it it's tough with
the heinz
because it has that flavor that i'm used
to yeah and it has that sweetness i get
you know
like that tangy it has a tanginess to it
we gotta thank our sponsor morning brew
graham i waste so much time just
aimlessly scrolling on my phone there
has to be a more productive way to spend
my time there is it's called morning
brew morning brew is a free daily
newsletter that could get you up to
speed on business finance and tech news
in just five minutes traditional news
could be so dense and boring but morning
brews articles are witty relevant and
also super informative i recently
learned in a morning brew article how
exactly the federal reserve hikes
interest rates and what that means for
me as an investor and that's just one of
many things i've been able to learn
through morning brews easily digestible
articles real talk guys i'm going to go
off script for a second but i have been
reading morning brew now for i think
almost three years i get the email every
single morning and without exaggeration
i open up probably like 80 of them and
they've really helped it a lot with my
video planning with concepts with new
ideas i would highly recommend it and
you are doing a disservice if you are
not signing up for them down below in
the description it is is the freest
thing that you can get besides a podcast
and it takes you just like 20 seconds so
it would mean a lot to us if you go
ahead and do it we'll be able to read
the same email every single morning all
you got to do is sign up for free at
morningbrooddaily.com
ich or use the link down below in the
description once again that's
morningbrewdaily.com
ich and go sign up with that link down
below in the description thank you so
much morning brew and back to the
podcast
when we did our research on this and we
uh we're doing the surveys we found that
people actually preferred something that
complemented food rather than
overpowered it now french fries because
french fries aren't inherently like
amazing you know in taste ketchup is a
very good compliment but for a burger or
something where you want a medley of
flavors and not just an overpowering
sweetness from heinz ketchup please is
preferred by cooks and chefs and people
that really value uh that natural flavor
and honestly it comes down to trying it
with like different foods too because
it's like we find that ours is like a
lot more versatile because the tomato
like people always say tomato like you
can finally taste the tomatoes rather
than just straight sugar and vinegar
that's good
yeah absolutely i mean between you and
the competitor 100 is you okay thank you
did you guys put uh did you guys put
sugar-free hinds on there uh we haven't
tried it because i think that would be a
great comparison because we all know
heinz right
but you guys are sugar-free so i think
one of the best comparisons that we
could probably do is having that
sugar-free heinz
sugar-free that's not good
so that's what we're saying i don't like
that i can't believe that pro you know
that past qa at heinz you know yeah i
walked over that's the worst one that's
what i'm saying like he had like eight
ten different ketchups and we were
trying them all and we were like this is
bad this is bad this is bad yeah like
so our goal is to be the best in the
class
best healthy ketchup you know when you
go to the store it's your go-to cuts
without compromise if you want to veg
out on hunts or heinz go ahead i mean
it's a quality product we're not going
to say you know it's not a good product
but uh if you're looking for something
healthier and take 75 percent of the
sugar out of there
kp is the way to go so how long have you
two known each other for fifth grade we
played football together yeah yeah i
went to different elementary schools and
middle school together and high school
and high school and
how old are you now 19 19 yeah we're
going to college
i go to university of miami and yeah i
went to the university of miami last
year but i dropped out just because
school wasn't really for me so nice i'm
just managing the business in wisconsin
and getting into some
real estate stuff
so yeah how much time do you spend
on it
because you're the one without uh
without the schooling right now yeah
well i mean i i pretty much split my
time between that and and real estate
because honestly a lot of the the
bottleneck of all this no pun intended
has been getting to that next level so
we can get to those new opportunities so
a lot of my time is spent just servicing
our current retailers obviously we have
a lot of farmers markets coming up and
events starting in may so i'm doing
those and then reaching out to new
stores and adding new retailers got it
and if you're trying to add new
retailers but at the same time you've
been reached out by other big retailers
like you mentioned their arrow one why
did you not go with air one when you
guys had that connection uh we don't
have the capacity um and i'll be honest
you know we produce in wisconsin we do
everything as you know freight rates
going up shipping out to los angeles is
not
the most efficient right now so ideally
you know we would central uh production
and logistics somewhere in like kansas
city or dallas at a larger facility
which we've talked to uh but right now
it's hudson and it just didn't make
sense at the time with the volumes we
were doing and the freight rates you
know a pallet was you know three
thousand dollars to ship out there it
it didn't make any sense so that's why i
mean they reached out to us we went
through the whole process with them um
but the west coast retailers right now
are a little bit more difficult for us
to get into and they also want to sell
it at a lower price
they want to buy it from you sorry i
don't know a similar price to what we do
in wisconsin you know we we reached
ourselves 5.99 we go on sale for 4.99
ideally we'd be at 4.99 go on sale for
3.99
so obviously listen it all comes down to
manufacturing we have a super solid
co-packer he's small he has i think
seven or eight employees
um but like he doesn't miss on a bottle
like every bottle is perfect but his
labor cost is
like relatively expensive
and so like we need to reach pretty high
minimum order quantities in order to get
that cost down which will then allow us
to get our cost down yeah to increase
our profit margin and be able to how
much would it cost to get you an erawan
um what was the cost of manufacturing on
that for you well it wasn't so much the
so this this goes back to the
overarching problem of chicken or the
egg do you do supply first or demand
first and we found that actually it's
usually supply and so
the the problem we we found and we this
was like last summer we were talking to
them is that when you
ship out there um again it's it's really
expensive so
we don't have the volumes to get to we
need to produce enough inventory at a
low enough price that we can then ship
it out at an affordable price it was
more like well we'll do a full
production run that we normally would do
for wisconsin and then ship it out but
that's a full day and you know a full
day is really expensive at a co-packer
um so for us it's really if we can get
the supply there if we can get inventory
costs down then it makes a lot more
sense for a whole foods an arab one we
can say hey
we have this ready and a warehouse ready
to go i mean it has a shelf life of
three years so you know last we have
this ready to go now we can ship this
out to you because we have our costs
right at that time
i'll be honest
shipping it there and getting in their
stores the price probably would have
been like seven or eight dollars a
bottle and granted it's more of a
premium experience but i don't know how
many people would have bought it for
seven how many bottles were they
interested in buying it didn't seem like
there was enough of it for you to make
it in that batch that would make sense
yeah well typically uh
it with retailers like them and then we
have a retailer named sendix in
wisconsin they have 17 stores so
relatively similar size they usually
order a pallet to start so it's 120
cases or 1440 bottles for those doing
math at home um
but that's usually like on a monthly
basis so you know with centix we can
almost do a palette a month at a place
we never really pursued before maybe
it's a half palette or a quarter palette
a month but
the most efficient freight weights rate
is going to be a palette unless you have
a full truckload which is you know 20
pallets of ketchup which is way too much
to start for them so
do you have data on like customer return
rates for example like they buy one and
they go back and buy the next yeah so we
have data through square and through our
website obviously when we sell to uh a
retailer they're not
out there seeing yeah yeah there's like
certain statistics you can actually pay
like you have to pay like 40 000 for
this data that will basically like they
work with all the stores and they see
how often people are actually like
buying it off the shelf but you know we
can see how many i guess how many cases
we're selling to each store on a monthly
basis yeah so that's kind of more so
what we go off of on the on the retail
side and as far as farmers markets go
which are actually really easy to keep
data on because it's hand in hand
um we actually see almost over 50
percent customer retention rate so
the thing is though some that's only
tied to like a credit card so if someone
uses a credit card again on square it's
like hey that's a repeat customer and it
gives you data on that the people that
pay cash which is actually a lot of
people farmers markets we don't
we don't keep data on that we probably
should but
you know it we would say between that
and our website we do see a lot of
repeat customers in fact i remember a
month ago i texted read i'm like hey did
you start the facebook ads again because
we stopped doing it we didn't have the
supply because we had all these orders
online and he's like no and i look back
and they're all
repeats yes we had been running ads
uh like two months ago so it was kind of
it was interesting how people like all
kind of ran out of their ketchup like at
the same time and then just like started
ordering again yeah so like 10 to 15
orders at a time you can see and it
wasn't
solicited it wasn't like you know we
were doing any branding or you know
promoting
and it was just like hey yeah these are
almost all repeat customers that was
pretty cool to see how long does a
bottle of ketchup last uh so 20 for
three years uh in that bottle no i mean
like if i buy it like what is the
average person
how long does it take to empty that
bottle before they find out
the average person about two months i
mean some people will go through it in
two days but yeah you know one to two
months
it seems like it would be better for you
to pitch to like food trucks restaurants
cafeterias stuff like this where they're
using a high volume exactly so that's a
big thing we're actually we work with
two restaurants that's at two
restaurants right now but one of them is
our leading like month-over-month
purchaser um so
the big thing there is a lot of these
restaurants are getting their hinds or
off-brand ketchup for you know super
cheap like a dollar fifty two dollars a
bottle whereas we're more so like four
four dollars for a 20 bottle wholesale
so you almost can't afford to do that
sort of vault can you what's the lowest
you could get it down to
you know so the absolute lowest
given quote we have right now we get
down to is producing that bottle for two
dollars and 20 cents that's the lowest
we have right now cost wise so you know
the thing is you have to remember with
restaurants too is they're not reselling
the product usually the one we actually
have is reselling it as well which helps
them but
they're not exactly you know they're not
making a profit if they have fancier
ketchup um but there's a marketing plate
if we get the cost down low enough that
that margin can be made made up at the
uh retail shop and i guess it would help
for you guys to know that our current
cost per bottle is about 320. so you
know with getting that labor down with a
bigger co-packer we can get it like you
know over a third of the cost down so
yeah so that's 320 including the cost of
labor to package it and everything
that's tomatoes bottles
labor everything all in except for
shipping you know wherever
it's going there's a little bit in there
for that so like we've brainstormed a
lot about the restaurants because
there's a lot of these gourmet
restaurants and we go we want to go to
them and be like you have this gourmet
food but you have the cheapest ketchup
possible like it doesn't make it it's
not lining up so that's definitely food
service is a big channel that we want to
hit yeah moving forward but first we
gotta thank our sponsor ftxus ftx is one
of the most complete crypto and finance
apps out there it allows users to buy
and sell nfts and crypto with no fees
whatsoever ftx is one of the largest
crypto exchanges in the world in terms
of daily users and trading volume and
they have a valuation of roughly eight
billion dollars you may have heard of
them through their partnerships with
steph curry tom brady coachella or the
miami heat stadium most exchanges charge
two to three dollar minimum fees on
every transaction i know gross but with
ftx you can trade as much as you want
all for free and their founder sam
bankman freed plans to give away 99 of
what he personally makes to charities
they even offer a crypto friendly debit
card allowing you to spend crypto at
millions of merchants worldwide they
also make dollar cost averaging easy
with things like recurring buys where
they can pull money directly from your
bank account on a weekly bi-weekly or
monthly basis and invest it for you
automatically so start trading crypto
and nfts with no fees today by using the
link down below in the description and
checking out ftx again the link is down
below in the description and with that
said let's get back to the podcast and
what was the profit for last year
uh it was it was seventeen thousand
seven hundred and seventy seven dollars
so almost twenty thousand dollars yeah
well we were in vegas you know um but uh
yeah no we and you have to keep in mind
last year we actually missed our two
biggest months we missed july and
september july we did like 200 in
revenues is you know just online sales
in september we missed almost all of it
because we simply couldn't supply the
product um
between those our biggest months are
june and august or they were last year
june we did fifteen thousand dollars and
uh augustine to eighteen thousand
dollars so you can imagine you know if
july or even some we missed fifteen
thousand dollars in additional revenue
and then september's probably half that
sometimes yeah
why did you miss those months so
there's a lot of factors we ran out of
product and so
when you like
long lead times
the direct reason was tomato paste um so
what happens is there's the tomatoes are
harvested in august and then they're
contracted out for the year so if they
run out you know of tomatoes in july
well you can't get more tomatoes until
august and they're harvested again so
for us we were talking to a tomato paste
supplier and like well we don't have any
tomatoes until the august crop we're
like okay so we didn't even have the
tomatoes to make our product uh never
mind we had the bottles and everything
but not the rest of the materials so how
is that not going to be a recurring
issue in the future uh well because we
have more volume now with them we can
contract our purchases out with them so
we're at least guaranteed a certain
amount and that's again why we actually
want to build up our inventory because
tomato prices are rising actually right
now there's a drought if we bulk up on
inventory again this lasts for three
years you know in an ambient state uh we
can get that cost down keep it there
all the tomatoes you know we order in
bulk we do it now and then for the next
three years if we don't run out or you
know if we do it's not an issue uh going
forward so that's again why we kind of
want to bulk up now versus now we're
kind of cashflowing and going day to day
yeah you really think you could sell
more in retail at arrowon grocery stores
than you could online
just that's that's a that's a great
question like we haven't we haven't even
explored online that much because
honestly for the product that we've been
able to produce like we've been selling
out to our stores yeah and in the months
may through october those farmers
markets and and events like the
wisconsin state fair um we did 10 000 in
sales just in those 10 days so that was
pretty insane so
um but no i mean i think that e-commerce
could definitely be huge you're
mentioning running the facebook ads how
much was shipping for if let's say i'm
on facebook and i buy one of these
things what's the total cost on that so
it depends so we have one bottle to five
bottle options on our site and a case 12
bottle option so it's eight dollar flat
rate shipping for one to five bottles
all right so that's expensive if you
just order one bottle you're spending 16
for one bottle of ketchup right and so
that's why and i'm sure you experienced
this with bankroll yeah uh bundles and
different you know variations of our
product and you know ordering three at
once for that price you know it's
divided among those uh bottles so the
idea is that yeah ordering one bottle
online and we also haven't looked at
amazon but amazon's pretty expensive for
that too
isn't you know the best value for us or
the customer but
the uh the best possible value is
usually in a bundle so if we have smooth
heat and dough sauce and you want to
trial three bundles for three together
and now the shipping is whatever eight
divided by three is you know two
something yeah a bottle okay do you have
any other flavors that you're coming out
with
yeah we have the we have the smooth heat
just the right amount of spice yeah um
so we're gonna try it yeah okay oh you
have it with you oh yeah it'll be a
prototype now i do want to say to the
fda and the crowd uh you know this was
made in a prototype phase this isn't
like so so i could get like a disease
from this well you know don't please
don't sue us if you could cause like
birth defects you have to give me one of
those you know prop 65 warnings yeah
well i just want to i just want to say
you know that's the reason we didn't
bring out originally because those are
obviously made in a food facility these
were not these are prototypes whatever
we do you like spicy things no
okay this isn't this isn't like insane
all right what's the future we want to
come out with like he might blame him
i'll try it my grandma would think it
was saying if you're watching donnie
mm-hmm no it's not the same
no that's good yeah so that's really
better than our main stuff so you know
our main thing too is like for
restaurants if you like that better if
we're not directly competing with heinz
hey we have a smooth heat option that's
kind of cool you know your customers
that's really different yeah so that's
that's why we're doing that we don't
have double shots with us because
mustard so across across all channels
like e-commerce retail and at the
farmers markets if you're going to buy
one you're going to want to try two
anyway so yeah
so like for our farmer's market if you
do one for six two for ten almost
everybody it's not like twenty percent
more it's literally like 75 percent of
people like oh i'm just gonna buy two
even the normal flavors yeah how are you
gonna expand this do you have any other
like plants or relishes and mayonnaises
and other concepts so we're starting
we're starting with ketchup and then
smooth heat and dodge sauce but
honestly barbecue is something that we
really want to hit because that has even
more sugar than ketchup so barbecue
first and then honestly get into kind of
the whole condiments please idea and
just branch off yeah the idea is that we
develop a brand
that
is premium enough that if you're not at
a cookout with our brand whatever it's
ketchup please or barbecue please
whatever it's like really man it's
almost like buying generic ketchup um
which you know isn't isn't a good move
at a barbecue so you know we developed
the brand line we have these cool
flavors develop the brand that way you
know it adds a lot of value for us and
the consumer
what's the end goal uh well
if you want the honest answer the end
goal is to be a big enough of you know
of a pain and a larger brand that you
know they'd probably buy us out but
honestly you know we're not banking on
that our plan is just to keep growing it
because and we could attest this too
like when we're at the state fair when
we're at farmers markets
we have so many people come up and like
wow i've been looking for this because
everything i've tried to taste bad or
they didn't even know there's a
healthier ketchup and
you know everything it's yeah it's it's
like it's almost the vehicle just to
kind of help like our whole motto has
been to help foster a healthier and
happier america so this is just like
it's just the vehicle so being able to
talk to people about what they're eating
and things that they may have not even
knew had 20 percent added sugar um it's
kind of turned into a passion project at
the same time
now my biggest thing is what's stopping
anyone else from from copying this and
just doing the exact same so the way i
address that question is what stops
curing dr pepper from competing with
bankroll coffee well obviously you have
a very well developed brand you have
kind of your your morals and everything
in line with that brand but with us
again
not only organic or no sugar added
tastes better which you've already tried
what the big competitors came up with
and we already beat them but it's the
derivatives and again it's it's
developing the brand which we have done
already where it's premium enough not
super premium premium enough that people
want to buy it and they want to talk
about it it becomes a talking piece you
know someone's table hey that's not
heinz it's not hans it's not you know
generic publix brand or whatever what's
that you know and people talk about it
and we see it happen at farmers markets
and festivals and everything so
it's kind of like if somebody copied us
go ahead i was gonna i just wanted to
point out
it's a catch-22 for heinz there's a
reason heinz no cigarette doesn't taste
as good as heinz because and i know
coca-cola has the coke versus coke zero
like debate the goatness but if heinz no
sugar actually tasted as good as heinz
then why would heinz with sugar even
exist you know what i mean if it were
healthier
so if they developed like a organic no
sugar added brand and kroger has it you
know up in the in the midwest you know
they do have that um first of all
doesn't taste so good and second of all
it's counter to their main product it
takes sales away from that main product
that they have
the traditional sugar added non-organic
product so
we kind of fit in between there
and we say well hey
if you want to do that go ahead but now
you should go tell your consumers which
would be a ben you know this would help
everybody now you have a healthier
option that tastes better but i don't
think they're going to do that you know
coke's always going to have sugar in
their main line
heinz is always going to have
traditional hinds
and that's just the way it's going to be
we're competing in you know this is our
one product it's the best it's without
compromise and you know that every time
you have it yeah and it's honestly like
most other food brands as i've been
attested too like we're not like we're
selling ketchup but really selling the
habit of buying the same ketchup every
time you run out of ketchup so
you know like you're so people people
live their whole lives eating hines and
then they come across us at a farmers
market or they see an ad online and
they're like
never thought about trying another
ketchup and then they try and they're
like i'm never going back what's their
favorite response at a farmer's market
and they say
they're like oh i don't like that well
there's two they say the other people
will say we don't like ketchup we say
well come try ours because usually they
don't like ketchup because it's either
too sweet or it just hasn't jived well
and they really like ours um or they're
like
no i'm heinz all the way you know
there's no way it's better and maybe it
isn't but it's different
um and people seem to really you know
like that as well like we don't have the
statistic but like when we were at the
wisconsin state fair we had thousands of
people coming in sampling every day and
i'd say it had to have been 95 percent
of the people that tried it liked it
like
if you don't like the only the only case
where they wouldn't is that the people
that are like i don't like tomatoes then
it's like that's kind of hard which is
here with you'd be surprised yeah people
don't like tomatoes they're like oh we
want to try your ketchup but i don't
like tomatoes i'm like okay it's going
to be tough yeah
sorry when i have a product it's made
with celery it's not yes
so besides the supply chain issues
what's been the biggest problem you guys
have faced
well um well supply chain is one of them
the second one
is we were producing at a facility in
2012 i'll tell you about 2020. yeah 2020
we did 7 000 in revenue okay it was the
same as the year prior and we only did
that by selling t-shirts because we
couldn't get product and it wasn't as
simple as supply chain issues
the uh the co-packer i won't name them
but the co-pack we were going to go with
not the current one that we have
basically kept pushing us off
you know our production day off and off
and off in the future and at the same
time we did that we've been producing a
commercial kitchen before
we lost our license for that and then
the fda wasn't doing in-person
inspections so you know we couldn't
produce um so that was a problem and
that continues to be a problem is that
we're actually now getting pretty close
to maxing out the facility we're using
now um and so we're looking we've talked
to a couple places in kansas city around
texas
in expanding our capabilities or maybe
going back to that place hopefully you
know rectifying anything that happened
but um it's really it hasn't been a
problem of demand it's really been a
problem supply and it's not just supply
chain it's actually getting the
production run going having it done
right when we did it at that previous
facility that co-packer over a quarter
of our product was defective had to
throw it out and it was the saddest
thing because you know food hungers you
know and hunger is a big deal in america
and i was like you know the seal wasn't
right and you can't sell it so we had to
toss you know bags and bags and bags and
bags of ketchup
so yeah yeah it all boils down to cost
like getting our costs down
to be able to pursue more opportunities
yeah really what do you think jack
it's the best ketchup out of all those
and the the other one the hot one
that's i love the hot one that's a
fantastic ketchup really really good
i like it i think that uh
the question like you know a hundred
thousand dollars for ten percent steak i
think 20 20 or 20 20 steaks
it's it's so hard for me to put a value
on it because i don't really know what
i'm doing but uh
but i know that the ketchup is good you
guys seem like good charismatic people i
believe in you guys especially not only
just the business but you guys just as
business owners
uh i think there's no reason why you
why you shouldn't be doing really well
if you guys don't get funding but also
at the same time it's like if you're
just rolling the profit back into the
cost of production and stuff like that i
just don't understand it's hard for me
to understand why you guys wouldn't be
able to like you said take advantage of
economies of scale and like get the cost
down and yeah like why wouldn't you just
take out a loan you could take out a
good credit card right now yeah that's
actually how well yeah so it's not that
simple we're 19 we just got our first
business credit card 7 500 limit and i
just want to point out student loans
student well there's that yeah you could
use your student loans
hopefully yeah hopefully they're not
watching um
but uh
okay we started this business with five
thousand dollars each right okay we've
grown it to at least this year doing
exactly what we did last year a hundred
thousand dollar revenue business with
only twenty thousand dollars in debt and
sure we can take out more doubt you know
we got a lot of debt from family and
friends um but you have to understand
that the the gap from
producing 2500 bottles in a run to 50
000
and supplying a couple independent
retailers to 500 whole foods stores
isn't
10
you know if you're making a profit of 10
or 20 or 30 percent it's really hard to
cash for that especially with other
expenses it's really you know once you
get to that point then you know okay
well if you're doing a hundred thousand
revenue thirty thousand profit it's a
lot easier to maneuver with things so
for us we've been doing the best we can
we've cash flowed
everything i mean we've literally taken
nothing out of the business and you know
we're doing fine but we really want to
take that leap and it's not as simple as
saying hey we'll supply a couple pallets
to you and whatever because we can't
even afford
to put an inventory that run yeah
everything evan just said but and it's
not just the money either like we are
like we've been actively looking for a
strategic partner to to be with us um
and somebody that can actually provide
value which i think that you obviously
can um especially on the e-commerce side
uh is that something that we really
haven't explored like we don't want we
don't want just like like what's got
like dumb money like somebody just
throwing their money in like we want
somebody who's gonna be actively engaged
and and um yeah
i worry that e-commerce is really
difficult and as because i know from
bankroll it's like even if you sell it
and we have uh we've been testing markup
first of all facebook ads are horrible
right now they were so expensive that
for the first time ever we lost money on
facebook ads because the cost was so
high and ad rates are going through the
roof because the apple update so just
like everything is just it's stupid
expensive um
so we stopped doing that but it's just
the margins are so bad with with
shipping and you have to sell a lot of
it
um are you i mean here's a hundred
thousand dollars is more than i wanted
to spend i mean i because i put on the
instagram uh post it's like 50 000.
where i thought like that was probably
the cap
um do you need a hundred thousand
dollars is that um
to really get done what you wanna do is
that
look i'll tell you this 100 000 is
probably more than we need and that's a
cushion
to do i'll just tell you the numbers if
you do 50 000 bottles of enter if you
didn't do 25 000 and it's about two
dollars about or a little bit less than
that that's fifty thousand dollars now
you know we probably do like twenty
thousand we have twenty thousand empty
bowels in inventory and actually that to
go back to your question before when
kovitt hit we'd always supply chain
issues and we're a really small brand
and they're like hey if you don't order
bottles now in bulk you're not getting
them for 54 weeks was the lead time so
we spent a lot of profit we spent almost
all of it and we'll show you to you in
the balance sheet we have 55 000
inventory of raw materials ready to go
um except for tomatoes and then you know
obviously the production so we bought
all these empty bottles we have those
sitting around
um and that's where we're going with
that but
um 50 000 actually would probably get it
done for at least a start at a larger
run on a call pack definitely for the
inventory because most of the co-packers
that we've spoke to have at least a
minimum of 20 000 bottles which would be
about 50 bucks so we could but we could
fill those you know with the funding
pretty much almost immediately i'd say
within a month we could we could have
everything ready at that facility ready
to go and fill it but as we kind of
alluded to in the last slide of our
presentation like there's other things
that there's other places that we would
allocate the funds and part of that
would be going to e-commerce um getting
to arrow on and whole foods and new
grocery chains and even distributors
there's a lot of kind of hidden costs in
that and getting actually the shelf
space so that and then some product
development stuff so it's not like it's
only going to um to the production you
know how much you would make if you sent
like let's say twenty
five fifty thousand dollars worth of
error on how much that would equate to
in profit because i i guess they would
well we have a profit margin of 30
percent but
i'm guessing not to arrow one right they
were lost that's a shipping and then
they won a little bit less um
so i'll be honest with you our first
step wouldn't be going to irwin it'd be
we have circo distributors they have 350
stores in the midwest that they're like
well when you're ready to go we can go
but
we don't again we don't have the
inventory to do that um
so at those stores especially it'd be 30
percent so
um on 50 000 you know for producing for
two dollars a bottle uh we're not 50 25
000 let's just say hypothetically we
used all fifty thousand inventory you do
twenty five thousand at two dollars a
balance fifty thousand
uh dollars of inventory and those that
two point five would actually we'd have
a higher margin we'd sell it for about
three point seven five uh wholesale and
they would sell for 599 or even less so
uh 3.75 minus uh two is one point seven
five times fifty thousands
it's eighty eighty seven five yeah
yeah on that inventory so
a lot of that would be our net margin
now granted ideally if we get our price
down to that we'd probably be at 3.99
which means we'd probably be selling
close to like three dollars you know
wholesale um so you're making a dollar a
bottle so about
50 grand in return on if it were all
used for inventory for 25 000 bottles so
50 grand you'd get back how much 50
a dollar a bottle
yeah that's our margin now right now
it's it's a little bit less because
again our facility and hudson are about
is 3.3 dollars so if we if we didn't
have a reduction in cost and we stayed
at three hypothetically around three um
we would be making
uh you know just over maybe well we
would be breaking even or if we're
selling the price we are now which is
what our margin is we make about one
point two dollars a bottle still yeah my
one thing is i don't really know
anything about ketchup um or about
anything in the retail space with
grocery stores i actually really like
the ketchup a lot i like the spicy one
the most especially ones really the
spicy one is really good uh that's my
biggest hesitation my only thing with
this is that um i would want to
if i if i did this it would have to be
with jesse wolfe and funny enough he was
on shark tank because he had a company
called oh dang hummus oh i've seen that
yeah yeah and he picked me up for the
airport and it was so cool he did a deal
with uh i think it was robert and um
oh who's it why am i blanking on the
other lady not barbara
laurie
yes robert and laurie oh dang hummus
and in negotiations afterwards
apparently you know i i i think i could
probably say it but but it ended up not
going as planned but anyway
i think a few years later he uh sold the
company and then now he came out with
something different but it's it's
similar to this it's not ketchup
but it it pairs kind of with ketchup and
so like if i could do this with him if
if he would be interested i would i
would do it with him because i because
he's done this before i've not and i'm
worried it's like if i throw money at
this
i know i'm sure you guys could go and
and fulfill those orders but like could
i help you on that
i don't know i would talk to him yeah
well it's boy i mean it's florida time i
could i could well i'm in florida dude
yeah
all right so i just sent him a text if
he doesn't get he should see this
and and see it uh quickly so
that's one thing i don't know who's on
your network but oh wait here he is hold
on
all right so i'll put him on here
yeah i'm gonna put you on the mic hey
what's up man hey okay so this is uh
super weird
but uh your name came up in a podcast
that i'm filming right now and you are
on camera is that you okay with that
yeah man absolutely
okay so uh remember i was telling you in
the car
that i wanted to do like a shark tank
style pitch
yep right anyway
i got uh
i got two young gentlemen here who
pitched me a product that's somewhat
similar to what you're doing and i
actually really like it a lot but i
would have no idea what to do and you
don't have to give me 100 answer now but
i said i wouldn't do it unless you and i
could do it together
but
it's a ketchup
it's called it's called ketchup please
and it's basically got no sugar
it's extremely healthy it tastes really
good they got a spicy version they got a
normal version we did the taste test
between all of us it's good um they
basically need money for more inventory
but uh
but yeah uh
i i like it i'm just curious
uh from your experience how difficult is
it to sell something like that because
you did hummus how difficult is that to
sell in stores
and scale up
so i've done products you know across
you know at this point i'm several
categories in a retail or
direct-to-consumer setting if you will
um
the thing about condiments that are
really challenging whether it's ketchups
or mayos or dressings
they're low velocity items
and it's really hard to scale
a low velocity item so an example of a
high velocity item would be like um
potato chips right
you open them you usually kill the bag
within you know one two
sittings right
um you know coffee coffee is another one
where it's a fairly high velocity item
right people consume coffee like crazy
ketchups mayo's condiments like salad
dressings you know think about it how
often do you actually finish an entire
bottle of salad dressing
most of us end up you know either buying
17 of them and throwing out the three or
four we never really got a chance to
finish or whatever right
so
they're challenging in that aspect
because they are a lower velocity item
secondly
the
brands right the iconic brands like you
know we'll take heinz for instance in
the ketchup space people
are really ruthlessly die-hard loyal to
these iconic childhood brands that we
grew up on and especially so in the
condiment space
again with chips there's a million
varieties and different occasions
whether it's tortilla chips or potato
chips you know whatever with ketchup
it's ketchup right you know you grew up
you like heinz it's really hard to break
that consumer away from heinz
um that's what we have found like when
we've done our products in the past and
you know our salad dressing
uh brand for instance had a really hard
time gaining traction with the flavor of
ranch
even though we made this super healthy
way better for you ranch product
you're really fighting a hard uphill
battle against a company like you know
hidden valley ranch for instance because
again it's an iconic product
uh and you're not using it that often
and when you do use it you're using it
pretty sparingly right
so
condiments in that realm are really
difficult from a consumer behavior
standpoint to break
the consumer's behavior um
so that's the challenge with condiments
and it's kind of a space that i'm a
little skittish on moving forward just
because you know we we went into it
we're still in it with the original
odeng brand
uh and you just have to find your tribe
so like for us we fit really well into
the uh plant-based movement you know
that was like something where we took
you know the dairy free out of it and
you know kind of hit the allergens and
so forth um they're like ketchup going
back to the products these guys are
talking about it it could be a great
product and i'm sure it is and it
probably tastes awesome
but it's a
it's a hard product to scale
um unless you have a tribe that's really
diehard and an example of a die-hard
tribe would be like
paleo back when paleo was really big
there were a couple brands like primal
kitchen that were able to you know
rally a tribe of people looking for a
paleo product uh and they were able to
succeed in you know
the space um keto you know keto is also
really massive for a while you know
we're seeing it kind of starting to you
know taper off now but that was another
time to make like a keto ketchup for
instance that had an opportunity to you
know build a tribe and kind of compete
with the hinds and those guys it can be
done but
it's just a really slow category with
um
you know some pretty gigantic
you know uh
goliaths in there if you will that we've
grown up with
so
it's interesting i would love to try the
product and it's not to say it cannot
succeed but it's definitely quite a
challenging category to be in i'm
curious though is it worth it to sell
condiments online because i said with
with coffee is the profit margins are so
thin with with shipping
or is it better for something like this
to go in store condiments would be tough
to do direct consumer but not to say it
can't be done
and one of the brands you know i'll
speak to for them to look up is trough i
think trough did something very um
unconventional
in the cpg space you know they made a
uber premium hot sauce
and by you know putting truffles in it
and having these you know
big price points
you know they were able to create a
direct consumer brand out of something
that normally you wouldn't be able to do
very easily
um
so you know there's that aspect of it
ketchup
of their variety you can do it retail
but you'd want to go through like you
know you're you're better for your
health channels almost immediately right
so your your whole foods and your
sprouts and you know your fresh markets
those you know higher end stores that
focus on cleaner label better for your
food products would be your springboard
into retail and probably the better out
jesse thank you so much uh i really
appreciate you taking the call now at
almost 11 o'clock your time so no
worries thank you um you'll get a shout
out here in the iced coffee hour we'll
put your uh instagram guys go and follow
him on instagram
and uh i'll see you soon in vegas
hopefully
yes sounds good brother i appreciate you
guys i'll see you soon bye bye
that was insightful oh my god my other
thought graham was like when they were
talking about looking for a new
co-packer i don't know if noel does
catch up i i'll talk to noel about it i
think at this point i'm probably going
as much as i love it i'm probably gonna
pass i'm just worried it's it's i
wouldn't be able to add the value from
the retail perspective and i was hoping
jesse would be in
or it'd be like a very easy yes because
he he's navigated this like multiple
times so i would trust whatever he says
he's kind of done it and can probably
replicate it i really like it though so
and i have a feeling on the bright side
i think you're going to sell a whole lot
of these
so yeah i know
i know uh because and we've never done
something like this but i mean this
could flop or it could get like a few
hundred thousand views i don't know but
regardless i guarantee almost everyone
watching this is is probably gonna order
something but it's like the amount that
that it would probably make sense for me
wouldn't make sense for you guys to give
up that amount of equity um 50 grand
would probably be i just wouldn't want
to take away that much i think honestly
it's worth more to you guys to keep the
equity because i i think most likely
you'll get a better offer after this
yeah the people at home you know if
anybody wants to invest uh and also any
food facilities i mean we have a couple
we're talking to you we have a couple
we're talking to but if anybody out
there is watching it and they're like
hey
i pack hot sauce or barbecue sauce now
we've got line space and
restaurants restaurants retailers if
you're sitting at home you want to try
ketchup please go to kpketchup.com
thank you guys i really appreciate that
thank you thank you can we keep a bottle
of ketchup or oh i told you our purpose
was to give you a bottle thank you
we got some shirts for you guys all
right no way
so uh our ask is one million dollars for
one percent all right equity in our
accounts yeah i'm sure you guys can tell
this this puts us at a valuation of a
billion dollars
yeah yeah so so
and we flew here today we to tell you
exactly why it's worth it um
it's because
we there's a problem right inflation is
bad right recently you've been talking
about it in videos right everyone knows
gas prices are high and recently those
videos that you've been talking about
specifically it's mainly coffee you know
in the when you're talking about
bankroll
so we know that you we know that you
guys want to offer bankroll for the
price that you're offering bankroll for
you know like we that's clear right yeah
we know and it's
it's crazy that even with the inflation
prices and of the coffee that you're
still maintaining that that low cost
that you wanted to achieve right so
props to you um but inevitably right
like if that keeps going right you're
gonna end up having to spend out of
pocket it's gonna be crazy and it's like
what are you gonna do right so
we have a solution for you in the form
of a whole array of products that you
can that you can sell okay
uh in order to compensate against that
and and hedge against that cost and you
can continue to sell your bankroll for
the same price you can continue to go
we wanted to start with the way
everybody starts the day
um
breakfast right
we think that everybody could start the
day with the iced coffee hour podcast
right so that's where we're
brainstorming right so so what we came
up with was
iced coffee hour crunch
wow
i want this is this uh like captain
crunch just like a rebranded or oh it's
iced coffee iced coffee cereal man
that's nice so
okay so i feel that so maybe maybe maybe
you know maybe it's not maybe it's not
clear maybe we need to move on to other
so like you know not everybody
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh my gosh
it says help jack reach graham
i'm curious if we help jack find his
date
so listen
maybe you guys know maybe you guys don't
like this maybe you guys don't like this
it's it's fine what's in the box so
listen so so
if if you if you don't like that right
and maybe it's because what did you guys
have for breakfast this morning what did
you guys eat did you eat protein bar
yeah so something convenient right
something quick not everybody can pour
milk in a in a bowl of cereal right so
we contacted a company that we got in
contact with them um and
we came up with a prototype that we've
never even seen like and we're gonna
have you guys open it on on air right
now for us um and that's um this right
here so we want you guys to open it
check it out we haven't even seen it so
i'm kind of excited to see it so it's
pop tarts yeah by the way it's it's made
with real money on the front the front
of it in the front here to throw money
look at the ingredients by the way
rice melted corn uh sugar
so check it out open it up it's like a
unboxing a uh
pokemon pack do i do i flip it around
which one's the hollow
oh no oh my gosh
how did
hold on
so yeah i mean it's crazy they you know
it's just we yeah it's it's awesome
that's the first time we've seen that
it's me and jack
no so yeah so yeah anyways anyways we
also came up with a couple hang on we
also came up with a couple of new
flavors what's in the box listen
it doesn't matter this is it's it's iced
coffee i want to taste the cereal i want
to taste it you can open the box you can
mess around with it if you want it's
made with real money but i to tell you i
got to tell you about these new flavors
jack jack let's see i gotta tell you
about these new flavors what are the new
flavors
not everybody likes plain coffee right
i'm not a big coffee drinker um but we
figured you know bankroll could use like
some exotic flavors you know so we came
up with a couple of flavors for you so
um we're starting off you know red
velvet okay right
we've got millionaire matcha okay that's
a good name actually we've got
caramel capitulation
you know what capitulation is got no
idea no it's when the
dude it doesn't it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter we got sushi night
because we know how much you guys love
sushi
right yeah yeah and last but not least
we got taco alarm clock because
sometimes you need coffee and a fiesta
you know
all right now just said that's on brand
a little change of scenery all right
oh yeah yeah yeah
we have
bankroll candle
with my robin hood portfolio how did you
guys get that screenshot
oh yeah this is right after you by robin
hood stop can i i'm just gonna stop can
you scoot towards me yeah yeah yeah
smell that shock there yeah smell that
what does it smell like coffee
smells like money
that smells like money yeah it smells
like mocha
i actually really like that
does that light
yeah yeah it's a real course yeah yeah
it's got it's got metal we were going to
bring a lighter but we were like we're
actually going to bring a blowtorch yeah
but we were like i don't know what goes
on what's funny is that there's a
canadian penny in here
you know that
oh
do you know that
i don't know i guess we didn't know
we'll talk to the guys we'll talk to the
guys okay yeah yeah he's going to eat
okay so like
everybody needs a candle sometimes right
you got to make the smell
in a room smell better right but you
can't you can't you just can't light a
candle everywhere right right it's you
can't light a candle in your car so what
we came up with was this the family air
freshener brand okay okay
we've got we've got graham gosh we've
got jack
we've got macy's oh my gosh and we've
got alex look at you you guys can you
guys can open that up and smell it but i
wouldn't i wouldn't smell it too close
if if it's it's pretty strong it is
strong it's pretty strong but you want
me to i'll open mine
or smell it
because i'm hungry ice coffee our crunch
man oh that smells good smell like jack
that is nice
yeah it also smells like mine vanilla
smells like yeah it smells like money
yeah big time that's the whole thing
smells like money yeah so
now that now that we have now that we
have
the room smelling good right now that we
have is smelling good i want to pose a
question to you right graham
bankroll right you guys sell coffee
beans right
right but have you ever considered
selling coffee beans
these are boron beans
bankroll coffee flavored beans
oh my gosh
is ernie
oh my gosh this is hilarious
that looks so good
anyways
so yeah we we also wanted to do a
product that no youtuber has ever done
before yeah
right it's it's actually crazy it's like
this is the most profitable idea i've
i've i think we've ever thought of we
thought of it a couple days ago we're
like this is great right so we've got
bank bars
no way yeah
so
[Laughter]
we've got you guys can open them up you
can do whatever you want really a gold
flavor we've got silver flavor and we've
got you know copper flavor
twenty dollars plus tags for one listen
listen
this is a premium
capitalist right this is a premium
product
um
anyways yeah i mean
no no other youtuber has ever thought of
this idea it's like the it's the biggest
you know oh my gosh um
yeah
there's 1300 calories in this
it's a premium what did you offer like
we want to pack a punch it's only 25.
you haven't you said you were hungry so
you have
924 percent of your total fat
deficiency right you should time his
money right you spend all that time
eating so do you take like just a little
nibble of this and you're good for just
a little bit just a little bit like a
crumb you think he would be pissed if i
if i this is expired by three years
i don't know i don't know what to tell
you maybe it's did you make this three
years ago i don't know
you make it expired it comes expired by
three years maybe um but anyways you
know with the caloric value of that
right if you eat the whole bar you're
really you're going to need to get to
the gym right and jack jack specifically
you right this is where we think you
come in right
am i trying we think
that you need to open up a line
of jack related supplements so this is
jack pre-workout
[Music]
jacked pre-workout flavored like iced
coffee
should i try some yeah i'm dude you're
going to be up all night
is that pre-workout it really is yeah
dude you're going to be up all night
iced coffee flavored whoa that's april
coffee
actually
yeah it tastes really good really
actually yeah it'll get you pumped
i don't want to be up all night no man
you're good you're good dude
how does it how does it feel oh my gosh
what does it taste like it's really it
tastes like uh like money yeah it tastes
like money yeah yeah exactly that's
exactly that's really that's really good
so you can't do 18 plus you have to be
18. you have to take you have to yeah
yeah
what happens if you aren't 18. we're
gonna make a children's one but we just
didn't have the time it's okay
three scoops of this yeah man just big
ones and 250 milliliters of water yeah
next thing we were thinking about you
know coffee is
a really complex food it's a really
complex drink
um a lot of people have
you know different feelings towards
different coffees they have different
coffee flavor preferences um and we
thought you know for those people why
can't everything
taste like coffee right so this is
another really unique product right
we have we have uh
in the in the bag here this is this is
coffee fi you can put this you can put
this on your on your pizza you can put
this on anything you want and it'll
taste like coffee really so it turns a
moly pizza into a grape pizza
it's just black and white so it's like
unflavorful and then the flavor comes
from 40
yeah yeah the profit margin is on this
earth it's it's also expired by three
years yeah i don't know
yeah it's it's i don't know it's
i guess we need to check the dates
but you know it's okay
so oh um so yeah that's that's eric's
idea no no no no no
at the end of the day where we're from
we're from upstate new york right so we
have bonfires i don't know if you guys
have like bonfires out here but we make
s'mores
um
i don't know if you guys know but like
marshmallows are easy like easy to find
they're literally like they're
everywhere right like
stuff this guy's got a marshmallow in
his pocket right he's got a marshmallow
in his pocket so
why'd you eat it so listen
we've got the marshmallows that's easy
right we've got we've got the bank bars
that's the new chocolate bar you use
what what is the last thing you need
right in the ultimate equation for a
s'more a gram right
and this is where we think this is
basically your namesake right and this
is this is the graham graham cracker
wow and you guys can you guys can open
this up check it out this will be also a
first time uh first time debut here
no way oh my god wow
no
holy crap
how did you guys could take them right
out of there you guys can open that up
yeah i almost don't want to open it so
oh wait it's already open graham you get
the gram i'll coffee-fy it oh my gosh
and we'll see how it tastes
oh my gosh
oh my gosh
so
so i know what you guys are thinking at
this point right you got a table full of
food right there's just all this food
there's all this food product i'll let
you get it why are you taking a photo of
me because right now because it's so
good
no no no no there you go i got a good
picture that's all i also wanted so so i
know what you're thinking like probably
some crazy company just came in here and
pitched you some crazy idea and it was
probably amazing surely not now so so so
you know
i
you see all this food product i know
you're thinking like where is where's
where's the where's the big idea where's
the revenue where's the technology
where's where's the where's that real
idea not the food right so that's where
we came up with the brilliant idea we
think of
the graham steph and nft right
so
we spent
days developing this nft we
we let we we you know
we consult we basically consulted you
know we went we went to the top of the
ranks right
legends in the space of youtube and and
web3 like garyvee logan paul right talk
to him make sure
you know it all checks out right
we
seven hours in right
we're working with fake software we're
working with 3d modeling software we're
working with unreal engine right we're
trying to make this nft perfect right 13
hours and it got a little bit better you
know still not there but after
like a ton of perseverance a ton of
learning right we ended up with this
right
so
and what graham with with
your sign off we would love to help you
sell this nft and donate it to the
charity of your choice
or not we don't really care we can just
you know we can just throw it away it's
fine yeah um
so
at this point
you're sitting here with all these
products we're pretty much done with the
products
and
we basically just wanted to thank you
guys for letting us come out here um so
we have we have a gift for you um we
know
that in a little bit here you're going
to be
fighting this madman right right we're
big fans of michael reeves but we know
that we all know here that he's probably
going to show up with a contraption
right he's probably going to show up
with some form of contraption he might
fight dirty and you're a respectable man
right you're not going to fight dirty
no you're not going to fight dirty but
we figured we'd get you something that
would help you get you an edge and let
everybody know
what you stand for when you're in this
boxing match
so
wow
this is the smash the like button
boxing gloves okay
just smash the like button for the
youtube algorithm when you punch
somebody hard enough in your match in
every future match of your boxing career
you'll be able to you'll be able to
punch them and you'll be able to remind
the fans you'll be able to remind
yourself of of what's what's truly
important you gotta really punch him
you gotta really punch him sometimes
sometimes
sometimes yeah sometimes you really
gotta punch him you know so i like this
yeah
so it smells good did you so what's this
regulation can you yeah of course yeah
of course
yeah we consulted we consulted with
everybody yeah yeah yeah so do you guys
have any questions or is this i'm in
you're in all right sweet that's awesome
where do we send the money i'll send you
the bank info okay perfect sweet
awesome this is incredible man thank you
so much i don't even know where to start
yeah this is like
craziest gifts ever yeah he's
amazing in all seriousness it's pretty
crazy that all that got through tsa yeah
yeah
oh did they not ask questions uh we left
them no yeah we left a little note we
said actually we said
we're meeting with the most famous
finance youtuber in the world we were
like we like plugged you all over the
place we're like so if you get a call
oh my god yeah maybe i don't know but i
love it thank you guys i really
appreciate it coming all the way here
great products you guys cool yeah i hope
that you're keeping all this because
there's no way we're going to oh yeah
we're going to keep all of it as long as
you get your free stock down below in
the description to center for pub keys
in the code grand cause that's worth all
the way up to a thousand dollars can you
do that more than 50 times because i
feel like i've done that 50 times a day
have you probably good yeah you got you
got your free stock too oh yeah all
right good thank you guys so much for
watching we'll link to your info down
below in the description as well where
they can watch this video
and uh until next time hey awesome cool
thank you really thank you man
thanks guys